foi bom dia meu nome é carol e hoje
estou aqui pra apresentar pra vocês
sobre o que a energia renovável
antes de começar eu sei que vocês estão
achando estranho porque uma menina de 10
anos está dando aula pra vocês mas eu
não eu quero que vocês saibam que não
estou dando uma aula estão simplesmente
conversando com vocês
bom o que energy energia tudo o que
produz ação em movimento
não sei se vocês pararam pra pensar como
nós somos independentes de energia no
nosso dia-a-dia realmente parar tudo
para nós andamos de carro dois motores o
cenário em que as fábricas funcionarem
bom quando vocês virão pra tudo para nós
usamos o celular computador à internet
realmente tudo no nosso dia a dia
agora eu vou falar sobre as fontes de
energias renováveis e não renováveis
bom o que são energias renováveis e não
renováveis ou aquelas que se esgotam com
o uso e que causou muitos danos ao meio
ambiente
e agora as fontes de energia não
renováveis só foi de energias renováveis
são aquelas que esses que você se você
não consegue construir entre elas renova
assim sozinhas com a natureza que casam
bem menos danos ao ambiente
esse aqui é um exemplo do petróleo a
fonte mais usada no mundo inteiro
esse é o carvão mineral e o xisto e essa
usina nuclear que que faz metais
radioativos que produzem calor e ameaça
nuclear
e esse é um exemplo do gás natural que é
o gás que sai do nosso fogão e agora vou
falar sobre as energias renováveis
esse aqui o exemplo das energias eólica
que a turbina giras informando energia e
esse é um exemplo de energia solar que é
o sol bate nessas placas informando
energia e essa usina hidrelétrica e esse
aqui é o etanol como como já disse você
não consegue construir
entre elas vão se renovando assim
sozinhas com a natureza como nessa foto
agora é com vocês quero que pense em
novas idéias para salvar nosso planeta
vamos votar eleger nossas casas e em
todo lugar que nós vamos
obrigada